I live in the west but I was growing up
on African upbringing right so
there's there's no reason why for all of
us to lose our moles and lose our heads
it becomes very dangerous when you get
put into a society or place and all of a
sudden now you start getting new new um
new ideas on how relationships should be
this is why people just decide they can
be a giraffe today and everyone's going
to say you can be a giraffe like I I
like like I am I'm quite aware of where
I am and what country I'm in and and
there's even some of the things I've
said you get people saying oh my gosh
you're so all of the things they'll try
to leave you for having it for a man
having a voice but I understand it so
I'm not gonna start to change my beliefs
based upon where I am no I'm going to be
the same person and I believe there's
going to be people because my my sisters
were raised as wives for other people's
sister for other people's husbands so
ultimately other people are raising
their their daughters um and their
sisters to be husbands um to be wise for
me so there's sorry I'm not saying wives
don't exist I'm not saying there's no
wives in 2022 I'm saying legally as a
man if I was a guy I would not want to
sign that contract right and I don't
think it's like does he love her enough
does he not it's it's it's a contract
that you are paid to leave I think you
can still do a ceremony with a ring in
your church whatever but legally why on
Earth would you do that as a guy like I
I honestly if you really understand the
legality of it I honestly think it's not
smart I think it's dumb I don't know if
I was following what you were saying
right right because I don't know if I
heard like
contradiction right can I ask you would
you say that you're in a traditional
relationship right now with your sweet
one
um traditional well no I'm not married
so yeah I heard you say that but would
you forget marriage like a traditional
relationship well well she listens to me
um she respects what I say hi in my
chest
see the reason why that hurts your chest
is because you was with a man that
didn't do anything for you
my last man did a lot for me but that's
that's not why it hurt my chest no but
I'm saying like see when a woman listens
to you because she trusts you in
leadership she understands that this guy
I'm with um he's not going to do me he's
not going to steer me down the wrong
path um he's a he's a strong leader
that's why she listens to me so I'm not
she doesn't listen to me because she
hasn't got her mind of course you can do
whatever she wants I do not control any
woman but when you're with a right man
you were actually fall into your
feminine and let him lead and do certain
things because you trust in his
leadership and a lot of times when women
go my chest is because they haven't
experienced that oh it's because that's
what you led with but I've heard what
you've LED with your leadership no but
what I mean is what I'm trying to say is
see even the shocking it that's not what
girls do now you want to be with a guy
that you trust his leadership absolutely
I thought you would listen to No no
absolutely absolutely
yeah so why does it hurt your chest
because it was what he led with no
because what I'm saying listen that she
listens to me is that a problem no it's
not no I'm just trying to understand
it's like what is it because to me
that's ideal
you don't think so it's ideal to have a
guy okay let me explain go ahead I want
to be able to listen to someone right I
have ears I'm going to listen but
perhaps if what you were to say is
she can trust me or something like that
or she lets see the problem but she lets
me lead her it was just the phrase and
the fact that that's what you led with
in terms of right but that's but that's
what submission is right if you believe
in submission that's trusting him even
when you don't want to yeah I think it's
for me it was the um choice of words and
the fact that it came with that was that
was the first that was what he learned
but that's the thing about you know
women like men when men speak they just
speak women hear things like oh my God
you could have said it differently yeah
but we can't deny that there is there is
meaning behind people's choice of words
so so that's that's it's just it is what
it is what I get is it I'm really tired
of women always telling me how to speak
like do you know how do you know how
much control
you literally just did no I didn't you
literally just didn't tell you how to
speak I told you what what would have
been but I'm not telling you how to
speak you go you go ahead speaking of
course I want to speak how I want to
speak but you're already telling me the
way I'm speaking is a problem in it
because you couldn't you couldn't yeah
you're right so it comes down to you not
me I haven't said I haven't said
anything disrespectful I didn't say you
haven't I'm talking about how I'm taking
it so don't turn it into no I'm not I'm
not that's not me no no okay you
literally just said you had a problem I
know what I said but we're not going to
confuse what I said and make it okay
okay so let me just speak right this is
this is something that tends to happen
with a lot of women right men speak
direct I'm a very direct speaker I will
say what I need to say I said that um
she listens to me all of a sudden you
had negative connotation with the word
listen so she listened to me because she
trusted my leadership they shouldn't I
shouldn't have to I know I understand
the word listen yeah so you're just
misunderstanding clarified can I can I
can I finish because we'll just keep
doing this yeah thank you okay no I
haven't misquoted you you said something
so I need to follow up on what you said
because because what you're doing is
what women always do to us men so we
speak direct we're articulate we say
something then you want to say you
should say it in a way like this we are
not women see the problem is the types
of men that you are attracted to
ultimately speak in a way where or or
act in a way where you may not like
um but when I'm speaking I'm never
speaking in a derogatory way about women
I'm never disrespecting women I'm just
simply saying that if you trust in the
man's leadership and ultimate submission
is showing is is love and when and when
you love a man you're not going to
question certain things so if it shocks
you to say oh um
um she listens to me it just says to me
that ultimately the types of men that
you've dealt with haven't spoken like
this or when they have your pushback
yeah yeah definitely I definitely think
I'm a good listener and I crave someone
that I can listen to right like when we
were speaking about the one that you
know was you called a bum I love that
um I couldn't listen to him he couldn't
lead and I crave that because I want
someone that I can feel secure with and
be like yeah you've got so then why why
choose somebody who you can't do that
with because I don't see it at first I
don't understand it he didn't have a job
um no no no he had a job he's a creative
so he he owns if you meet him and walk
into his office you'll think wow this
guy's got it together but that's not the
case but then you were still supporting
him I was supporting him yeah so the job
was the job wasn't making money no
because it's like it's um
it's not a facade it's just you know
there's there's a job one month and next
month nothing you might get a massive
sorry he's like a contract yeah exactly
how long did you support them for uh six
months and then and then you cut it off
you couldn't do it anymore yeah yeah
that's not too long that's not that bad
yeah some girls come out and they say
like three years
there was a girl on here I was like I I
done a course on what is it um on music
because he was a rapper and I was gonna
be like this producer I'm like yeah you
like really invested in that bomb do you
know what I'm saying this ain't build a
bomb
I think that's a problem with now as
well because of course Instagrams are
like people's CVS and stuff and it's so
easy to portray yourself one way and
then when you go to their house yeah but
who do you think is more deceptive men
or women on Instagram I think both oh
come on I think women are specifically
and like lifestyle but guys with like
you know money girl you think I think 90
of guys have ass Instagrams like they
have like 500 followers with three
pictures most guys
though it's not even that you see men
like I I tend to find that a lot of men
they don't know how to take pictures so
you might look at their Instagram and be
like oh my god wow he's so not my type
you see him in person and it's a whole
different story I fall in love with
men's comments on Instagram like if I if
I see you think in a certain way and
like I don't even know what you look
like you could just be a Grace Circle
and I'd be like
now you wouldn't fall in love with mine
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible